I APPRECIATE YOU JOINING ME.
OBVIOUSLY THIS WILL CONTINUE ON.
AS AMERICANS WERE PREPARING
TURKEYS AND TRAVELING, THE MEDIA
WAS CONCERNED WITH SOMETHING
MUCH MORE IMPORTANT.
>> LEAVING THE WHITE HOUSE AND
SPEND THANKSGIVING IN FLORIDA.
>> WEST PALM BEACH WHERE THE
PRESIDENT IS SPENDING HIS
THANKSGIVING HOLIDAY.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS ARRIVED
AT HIS GOLF CLUB THAT IS HERE
HAND SEEMS THAT'S HOW HE WILL
SPEND THE DAY TODAY.
>> ALL RIGHT.
IT DIDN'T STOP THERE.
NEWS WEEK PUBLISHED AN ARTICLE
WITH THIS HEADLINE.
HOW IS TRUMP SPENDING
THANKSGIVING TWEETING, GOLFING
AND MORE?
BUT WHAT THE MEDIA DIDN'T KNOW
IS THAT THE WHITE HOUSE PLANNED
A TOP SECRET TOP TO VISIT U.S.
TROOPS IN AFGHANISTAN.
>> THERE'S NO WHERE I'D RATHER
CELEBRATE THIS THANKSGIVING THAN
RIGHT HERE WITH THE TOUGHEST,
STRONGEST, BEST AND BRAVEST
WARRIORS ON THE EARTH.
WE THANK GOD FOR YOUR HEALTH AND
ALL OF THE THINGS YOU'VE DONE.
YOU'RE SPECIAL PEOPLE.
YOU DON'T EVEN KNOW HOW MUCH THE
PEOPLE OF OUR COUNTRY LOVE AND
RESPECT YOU.
>> WELL, THIS FORCED THE MEDIA
TO SORT OF BACKTRACK.
NEWSWEEK UPDATING THEIR HEADLINE
TO TWEETING, GOLFING AND
SURPRISING U.S. TROOPS IN
AFGHANISTAN.
JOINING ME NOW TO REACT, CALEY
AND JENNIFER, DEMOCRATIC
STRATEGIST AND FORMER CAMPAIGN
STAFFER FOR HILLARY CLINTON'S
2016 PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
LADIES, THANKS FOR JOINING ME.
>> GOOD TO JOIN YOU.
>> IT WAS A GREAT THANKSGIVING
FOR THE TROOPS IN AFGHANISTAN.
IT WAS AN ACTION I WASN'T
SURPRISED TO SEE THE PRESIDENT
TAKE.
BUT CALEY, THERE ALMOST IS THIS
CONFIRMATION BIAS THAT THE MEDIA
SEE WHAT'S THEY WANT TO SEE,
THAT GO WITH THE NEGATIVE NO
MATTER WHAT.
ALMOST IRRITATED WHEN HE DOESN'T
FIT IN WITHIN THAT NARRATIVE.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON -- IT'S NOT
NEWS FOR US TO SEE THIS.
IT'S BEEN THREE YEARS.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON WHERE THIS
IS LEADING?
>> WE'VE SEEN IT REPEATEDLY,
TAMMY.
EVERY DAY, SOME RENDITION OF A
FAKE NEWS STORY.
THEY REPORT SOFTLY SOMETHING
HABIT PRESIDENT TRUMP OR HIS
ADMINISTRATION.
THEY UPDATE IT OR CORRECT IT, IF
WE'RE LUCKY, IF THEY HAVE ONE
IOTA OF HONESTY.
THEY DO SO ON THANKSGIVING
EVENING AT 6:17 P.M. AS THIS
CORRECTION WAS GIVEN.
ANOTHER A.P. STORY CORRECTED ON
THE FRIDAY BEFORE THE FOURTH OF
JULY WEEKEND.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
THEY SEE WHAT THEY WANT TO SEE.
ALWAYS THE NEGATIVE.
PEOPLE SEE THROUGH IT WHEN ABC
POSTS VIDEO FROM KENTUCKY AND
ACT AS IF IT'S FROM A SYRIAN WAR
ZONE.
THIS IS WHAT EXPOSES THE MEDIA
AND THE MORE THEY DO IT, THE
MORE PEOPLE WAKE UP AND GET
BEHIND PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> THIS IS, I HAVE TO SAY,
JENNIFER, IT'S AN INTERESTING
DYNAMIC.
THIS IS AN INDUSTRY THAT ALL
AMERICANS HAVE RELIED ON.
IT'S AN IMPORTANT AMERICAN
INDUSTRY AND IT SEEMS TO BE
DESTROYED.
THEY'RE DESTROYING THEIR OWN
MEDIA AS WE MOVE THROUGH THIS.
A GOOD DEMOCRACY NEEDS PEOPLE TO
QUESTION POWER AND TO BE TAKEN
SERIOUSLY.
ARE YOU -- OBVIOUSLY I'M
GUESSING YOU DON'T LIKE
PRESIDENT TRUMP BUT ISN'T IT
IMPORTANT FOR NO MATTER WHO THE
CANDIDATES ARE TO HAVE A MEDIA
THAT CAN BE TRUSTED?
>> YES.
THE PRESIDENT HAS SPENT THE LAST
SIX YEARS DENIGRATING ANY MEDIA
SOURCE THAT ISN'T THIS NETWORK
AND OTHER --
>> WITH THIS KIND OF THING CAN
YOU BLAME HIM?
>> NEWSWEEK TOLD THE TRUTH.
THE MEDIA WAS NOT TOLD THAT THE
PRESIDENT WAS GOING TO
AFGHANISTAN.
IT'S A SECURITY MEASURE.
THERE WAS NO WAY THAT NEWS WEEK
WOULD REPORT THAT BEFORE HE
SHOWED UP.
THE REST OF THAT HEADLINE IS
TRUE.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETED AND HE
PLAYED GOLF ON THANKSGIVING.
HE TRAVELED TO MAR-A-LARGO.
HE'S ACTING PRESIDENTIAL FOR
ONCE WHEN HE GOES THERE AND
GREETS OUR TROOPS.
IT'S NOT ABOUT SHAMING THIS
PRESIDENT.
THIS PRESIDENT DOESN'T STEAL
SHAME.
OTHERWISE HE WOULD HAVE RESIGNED
YEARS AGO.
I'M PROUD THAT HE WENT TO
AFGHANISTAN TO SPEND TIME WITH
THE TROOPS.
THE MEDIA DIDN'T LIE.
THEY SAID WHAT HE DID WHEN THEY
WERE ABLE TO SAY IT.
>> IT'S POSSIBLE AND I KNOW YOU
WORKED WITH HILLARY AND SHE HAD
TROUBLE WITH THE MEDIA AS WELL
AND DOES STILL TO SOME DEGREE.
ISN'T IT POSSIBLE THAT WHILE YOU
MIGHT NOT LIKE THE PRESIDENT'S
STYLE THAT HE DOES CARE AND THAT
THINGS THAT SURROUND THIS
COUNTRY AND AFFECT THIS COUNTRY
THAT IT DOES MATTER TO HIM, THAT
MAYBE -- MAYBE YOU DON'T AGREE
WITH STYLE OR THE NATURE OF SOME
OF THE THINGS HE'S DONE BUT IT'S
SO IMPORTANT THIS NOTION THAT IF
HE DOESN'T FEEL SHAME.
HOW CAN YOU REALLY KNOW THAT
ABOUT SOMEONE?
UNLESS IT'S RED RIC
UNLESS IT'S RED --C
UNLESS IT'S RED -- RHETORIC FOR
YOU.
THERE'S A REASON WHY THE
PRESIDENT, CALEY, GOES AFTER THE
MEDIA.
I WOULD LOVE HIM TO HAVE A
NORMAL RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
MEDIA.
BUT THEY MADE IT IMPOSSIBLE WHEN
THEY SEE HOW THEY RESPOND TO
EVERY SINGLE THING HE DOES.
IS THERE ANY WAY WE CAN BRIDGE
THIS GAP WHEN YOU HEAR THINGS
THAT ARE SO PERSONAL THAT ARE
ALSO SO UNTRUE?
>> THE ONLY WAY TO BRIDGE THIS
GAP IS FOR THE MEDIA TO STAND UP
AND DO WHAT THEY'RE THERE TO DO,
WHICH IS TO REPORT FACTS,
HONESTLY.
NOT TO ATTEMPT TO SHAPE PUBLIC
OPINION.
THAT WON'T CHANGE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE LOVE THIS
PRESIDENT IS HE CALLS OUT
INSTITUTIONS THAT HAVE LONG
BETRAYED THIS COUNTRY.
HE CALLED OUT THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY AND SAID NEITHER OF THESE
PARTIES ARE WORKING FOR THE
PEOPLE AND THEN HE CHANGED THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY TO BE A VEHICLE
THAT WORKS FOR THE PEOPLE AND
ANSWERS TO THEIR DEMANDS OF WHAT
THEY ELECT PEOPLE TO DO HE'S
CHALLENGED INSTITUTIONS THAT
HAVE BETRAYED THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC.
THEY SEE THAT AND I GUARANTEE
YOU THIS PRESIDENT WINS WITH
OVERWHELMING SUPPORT.
THAT MAP WILL LOOK REDDER IN
2020.
>> THAT IS ONE OF THE ISSUES
THAT DEMOCRATS DON'T LIKE.
BUT THEN WE SEE SOMETHING ELSE
GOING ON.
LADIES, LIBERALS REVEALING THEIR
TRUE SELVES.
JENNIFER, ONE SECOND HERE.
>> RELY --
>> EXCUSE ME.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON FOR A
SECOND.
WE KNOW YOU DON'T LIKE HIM.
YOU'RE A YOUNG WOMAN.
THIS IS NO WAY TO LIVE LIFE.
IT'S THANKSGIVING.
WE'RE MOVING INTO THE HOLIDAY.
POLITICS CAN BE ROUGH AND TUMBLE
BUT MOST OF US THAT HAVE SEEN
THIS UNFOLD REMAIN SHOCKED AT
THE LEVEL OF THE VITREAL.
IT'S NOT GOING TO HELP YOUR
PARTY NEXT YEAR.
THIS CASE IS AN EXAMPLE OF THAT.
AS GOVERNOR MARTIN O'MALLEY
PUBLICLY HARASSED ACTING
SECURITY SECRETARY KEN
CUCENELLI, YELLING ABOUT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S IMMIGRATION
POLICY.
HE TOLD FOX NEWS, O'MALLEY
PUSHED HIS WAY THROUGH THE SMALL
GROUP TO CONFRONT ME FACE TO
FACE.
STILL CURSING ME.
THE PRESIDENT, MY ITALIAN
ANCESTRY.
HE GOT UP IN MY FACE, BUMPED UP
AGAINST ME, INVITED ME TO TAKE A
SWING AT HIM AT WHICH POINT I
SAID MARTIN, ONE OF US HAS TO
RISE ABOVE THIS AND IT'S
OBVIOUSLY NOT GOING TO BE YOU.
JENNIFER, WAS THAT APPROPRIATE?
IS THAT ALL RIGHT?
>> WELL, I CAN'T SPEAK TO FIRST
HAND KNOWLEDGE OF WHAT HAPPENED.
TO ME THAT SOUNDS WILDLY
INACCURATE FROM THE STORY
RELEASED.
I KNOW GOVERNOR O'MALLEY.
I KNOW HE'S PASSIONATE ABOUT
WHAT HE WAS TALKING ABOUT.
IF THIS ADMINISTRATION CAN'T
TAKE BEING SPOKEN TO ABOUT THEIR
POLICIES THAT ARE HURTING
PEOPLE, THEN I SUGGEST --
>> JENNIFER, THIS IS OBVIOUSLY
THE OTHER PROBLEM.
EVEN O'MALLEY IS NOT DENYING THE
NATURE OF WHAT OCCURRED.
THERE'S MULTIPLE WITNESSES,
BARTENDERS, THE WAIT STAFF,
OTHER PEOPLE THAT WERE THERE --
>> HE SPOKE TO HIM IN A LOUD
BAR.
>> EXCUSE ME.
IT WAS AN INVITATION TO START A
PHYSICAL FIGHT USING OBSCENITIES
AND INSULTING HIS ITALIAN
HERITAGE.
WE'VE SEEN THE ENCOURAGEMENT TO
CONFRONT AND ATTACK TRUMP
SUPPORTERS.
WE'VE SEEN IT HAPPEN IN PUBLIC.
CALEY, THIS IS A FORMER
GOVERNOR.
SEEMS TO THINK THIS IS
APPROPRIATE BEHAVIOR.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THE "WASHINGTON POST" REPORTED
IT AS YOU KNOW, MARTIN O'MALLEY
NOT DENYING IT.
AS YOU SAID A FORMER DEMOCRAT
GOVERNOR ENGAGING IN THIS
BEHAVIOR.
SHOWS YOU THERE'S A VILE
ANIMOSITY ON THE LEFT THAT
CANNOT GET OVER THE FACT THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WON.
IT'S WHY SARAH SANDERS WAS NOT
ALLOWED TO EAT DINER IN A
RESTAURANT, WHY KIRSTJEN NIELSEN
WAS CHASED OUT OF A RESTAURANT.
>> YOU DON'T SEE THIS ON THE
RIGHT.
THIS IS NOT WHAT REPUBLICANS DO.
THIS IS WHAT THE LEFT DOES.
WE GO TO THE BALLOT BOX.
>> AMERICANS ARE SEEING THAT.
JENNIFER, I'VE BEEN TOLD AN "THE
INGRAHAM ANGLE" PRODUCER WAS IN
THE PUB AND CONFIRMED WITH THE
WITNESSES THERE AND THE WAIT
STAFF.
WOULD IT BE SO DIFFICULT TO SAY
THAT WAS WRONG AS OPPOSED TO
DENYING IT AND PRETENDING IT
DIDN'T HAPPEN?
>> I'M GOING TO TAKE YOUR WORD
THAT VIOLENCE IS NEVER THE
ANSWER.
IF AN ADMINISTRATION OFFICIAL
CAN'T TAKE BEING SPOKEN TO --
>> THAT'S NOT WHAT HAPPENED
HERE.
THIS IS THE ISSUE.
>> THIS IS NOT --
>> I WASN'T THERE.
I DIDN'T SPEAK TO GOVERNOR
O'MALLEY.
>> Neil: SEE, THIS IS WHY THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE SUCH TROUBLE.
LADIES, THANKS VERY MUCH FOR
JOINING ME.
I APPRECIATE IT.
THIS IS THE PROBLEM, RIGHT?
THIS IS THE NATURE OF WHAT WE'VE
GOT HAPPENING IN SOCIETY.
THERE'S A REFUSAL TO ADMIT IT.
FOR CALEY, MANY OF YOU DON'T
KNOW, SHE'S JUST HAD A BABY, A
NEW MOM.
CONGRATULATIONS.
I SAW IT ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
BEAUTIFUL EVENT.
LITTLE BLAKE, ISN'T THAT RIGHT?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
AND I SAW YOUR MESSAGE ON
TWITTER.
THANKS SO MUCH.
WE'RE SO BLESSED.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU KNOW, WITH EVERYTHING GOING
ON, THIS IS THE ENTIRE -- A GOOD
REMINDER WITH THIS SEGMENT.
LIFE MATTERS, ENJOYING YOUR
LIFE, BEING ABLE TO DEAL WITH
CERTAIN ELEMENTS OF REALITY,
BEING POLITICAL IS FINE BUT IT'S
ALSO THE FACT THAT FAMILY
MATTERS AND BEING ABLE TO DEAL
WITH THE NATURE OF WHAT'S